welcome back shut up
they're plotting me
people
it is mean there's a babbling old man at
large who doesn't know who's in charge
yes it's gaffs like this that led to one
conclusion Biden lives in the Land of
Confusion
it's for President Biden even for him no
he doesn't have covet for the 14th time
the virus prefers living hosts
but at least he knows who the president
is right he was also kamala's birthday
turn 30.
happy birthday great president
[Laughter]
all right so he keeps calling Kamala the
president
maybe they're just role-playing ew
that's ew I know but it's not like he's
spaced out when asked if his wife
supports him running for reelection I
have not made that formal decision but
it's my intention my intention to run
again and we have time to make that
decision
uh Dr Biden is for it
Mr President oh Dr Biden thinks that my
wife thinks that uh
that I uh that were that were doing
something very important you know if
that was a concussion test he definitely
failed
Joe's brain right now hit the scans look
like an Etch A Sketch
but maybe it's hard to answer softballs
while making one in his pants
foreign
but hey at least he didn't get lost in
the White House Garden during a tree
planting ceremony right
[Music]
that was a cornfield maze we'd never see
him again
too bad Dr Jill's not a botanist I think
her husband has Dutch elm disease
someone please replace the nuclear
football with a briefcase full of
ping-pong balls
but how does his staff keep letting this
happen it's like they're letting him
wander on purpose help the poor guy out
maybe if they flash a light he'll walk
toward it
then again maybe there's only so much
they can do take this for example during
a White House Event tape last week Biden
claimed that his student loan bailout
was passed by a vote if you don't have
one of those loans you just get 10 000
written off it's passed I gotta pass by
a vote or two and it's in effect wow he
sounds like it sounds like cat tip
no no one voted on it it was an
executive order he doesn't seem to know
what he's signing maybe they told him it
was for free government pudding
this guy's running for president again
God help us anything to add Joe
no no no no no look I know what's going
on
I'm sharp as attack Jack
and uh
look one vote one vote passed by one
vote me my vote that's what it is look I
got this uh look it's like that old joke
right you line 10 guys up against uh
wall and uh
you know bartender says uh
well you know how that one ends
[Laughter]
January 6th
January
Rob I gotta what is up with this staff
like they see this and yet they every
after every speech or ceremony or
whatever they just let him wander why
don't they have a a plan well I mean you
know at least it's not Easter because
then they had the staff member dress up
as the Easter Bunny to sort of direct
them around Joe but he's just so old and
just so out of it you know I he's so old
that I heard he sniffed the child that
was actually above 13 years old I heard
he is so old he actually read the
teleprompter correctly so it just it's
it's outrageous we really need to stop
electing 130 year old corpses as
president 81 million people you know
those 81 million people they really uh
need to think about that next time yeah
that's true Iris um
he mentioned Carmela's name and then he
called to the president do you think he
just forgot her name again like he just
like he just went okay first of all how
dare you expect him to connect two
paragraphs Gutfeld back okay he was
clearly talking about two different
things yeah
[Applause]
that makes sense we gotta call that yeah
okay
that's number one
and number two the reason why no one's
helping him because you're going to get
that I can do it myself oh yeah get off
me yeah where am I
like so that's why they're not helping
him plus if they're anything like me
security we got a sense of humor so they
probably don't tip well yeah so let his
ass wander off you know
that's a reflection
that's how well you know your secret
service and your bodyguards like you
when they let your ass do that all the
time exactly some the new guy's going to
help no just let it go let it unfold
trust me it'll be great cats
cat what about like he that he didn't
sound well no I know you that concussion
test thing you said you're making a joke
I actually think that's not a bad idea
yeah like he won't do he won't take
questions after he gives a speech what
if we're like okay we'll give that up
concussion test after every single
speech I think it's sad to have to
suggest that but what's even more sad is
there's no way they'd allow that to
happen yeah like all politicians lie
this politician were like does he know
he's lying yeah like I you can't even
really call him a liar because he you
don't know if he knows where he is
anymore at this point yeah it's in like
Cyrus it's like every tie yep it's
getting worse and they and Emily says
he's going to run again but maybe they
just haven't told him he's not running
it's like taking grandpa's car keys away
totally like you can't run anymore we're
gonna take your uh whatever it is that
you would take well even if they told
him he would forget it two seconds later
I'm supposed to be an EMT there's the
alert and oriented times four right it's
the test you ask someone to make sure
that they're conscious and there's four
questions it's basically like do they
know who they are where they are
approximate time and date um and what's
happening ironically one of the
questions is like who's the president so
literally if you were to ask him give
him and the the AO times four
he would fail
every question because he certainly
doesn't know who he is or where he is or
what time of day it is or approximately
what is happening or who the president
is but you know what he knows enough to
do he knows enough to say full sentences
like no serious guys until you're 30. as
he sniffs a little girl's hair so to me
he's he's dead and also disgusting you
um I forgot you were an EMT yeah oh wow
that must have been fun huh where were
you uh in was when I lived in Stinson
Beach I'm sorry could you imagine that
like I'm in a car accident dying
[Laughter]
I don't know what I'm going to be doing
right now
anyway you gotta go hey Sean Hannity
here hey click here to subscribe to Fox
News YouTube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else